entre 7 et 9 aller-retours par jour
entre Longueuil et le centre de Montréal
150 km quotidiens principalement en
mangeant le Saint-Laurent ce chauffeur
le fait depuis 25 ans et il a un petit
pincement c'est un deuil parce que c'est
notre circuit le plus lucratif c'est la
clientèle me connaît depuis les années
j'ai toujours adoré faire du
centre-ville j'aime beaucoup conduire
les articuler mais bientôt des milliers
de passagers qui arriveront au terminus
Panama à Brossard seront dirigés vers ce
tunnel pour embarquer à bord des
voitures du REM direction le centre
ville de Montréal seul le REM pourra
emprunter le pont Samuel de Champlain ce
qui a exigé une refonte totale du réseau
de Longueuil ça concerne davantage les
secteurs qui sont au sud de la française
c'est là où il va avoir un impact plus
grand où les circuits sur quel rompu
directement jusqu'au centre-ville mais
vont être interconnectés avec les trois
stations sur la Rive-Sud il y aura au
total 1400 voyages quotidiens vers les
stations du Rennes on contrat 5
nouvelles lignes d'autobus et 27
circuits ont été modifiés une carte
interactive est déjà en ligne pour que
les usagers puissent simuler leur futur
trajet le RTL attend maintenant le
signal du REM pour se redéployer c'est
des PQ un frais est encore flou sur la
date de mise en service du tronçon
Rive-Sud mais ce ne sera pas avant la
mi-avril et chez les habitués de la
traversée du pont en autobus il y a
quelques interrogations
est-ce que ça change quelque chose ça
nous amène l'endroit où ça doit nous
mener à la même fréquence pour moi ça
fait pas de changement peut-être
dépendre du prix aussi ça serait pas le
même les gens vont pouvoir bénéficier
d'une tarification intégrée
métropolitaine la même que partout
ailleurs sur le territoire l'autorité
régionale des transports métropolitains
doit faire de nouveaux ajustements à sa
grille tarifaire avant l'entrée en
service du renne
ici Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal